[Musique]
vous êtes sur Public Sénat bonjour à
tous qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
dans la gestion de la crise sanitaire
qu'est-ce qui peut être doit être
améliorée en cas de nouvelle vague ou de
nouvelles épidémie c'est l'objet de la
commission d'enquête mise en place cet
été par le Sénat aujourd'hui c'est
Cédric Hau le secrétaire d'État chargé
du numérique qui est auditionné on
regarde l'audition on en reparle juste
après
d'abord celui du contexte dans lequel
l'idée est le projet d'application
à émerger celle du début celle de la
période qui a un peu précédé puis qui
était celle du début du confinement en
mars 2020
qui était je le rappelle à ce stade une
période de grandeurence mais aussi de
très grande incertitudes sur l'épidémie
et son évolution
et il m'a semblé naturel dans le
contexte
d'inquiétude de mobilisation qui était
le contexte d'alors et compte tenu des
initiatives que nous voyons pointes dans
d'autres pays de faire en sorte de faire
ma part dans la lutte contre le covid et
donc de m'assurer que la France tout
comme les autres pays d'Europe et comme
certains autres pays dans le monde
travaillait au développement de d'outils
numériques afin d'aider à combattre
l'épidémie cela étant dit il y a trois
principes qui nous ont guidés depuis le
début et sur lequel je voudrais revenir
je pense qu'il
vous ne manquerait pas de revenir dessus
dans les dans les questions le premier a
été cela me semble important de toujours
répondre à un besoin identifié par la
communauté médicale et scientifique
sans chercher à imposer de solutions
technologique
je rappelle que la capacité à stopper au
plus vite les chaînes de contamination
c'est très vite imposé comme un levier
majeur et décisif dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie et que la communauté des
épidémiologistes a commencé par
l'Imperial College et l'Université
d'Oxford sous la direction du professeur
Christophe Razer qui de mémoire et le
premier à avoir publié des papiers sur
la question des outils numériques la
communauté des épidémiologistes donc
c'est très vite intéressé aux
possibilités que pourrait offrir le
numérique pour soutenir et accélérer le
processus
les applications de contact Racing
pardon de cette anglicisme sont ainsi
apparus très vite comme l'un des sujets
importants de mobilisation numérique au
service de la stratégie de lutte contre
l'épidémie notamment au niveau européen
c'est net néanmoins j'ai l'occasion de
le dire en introduction qu'une part du
parti pardon de ce que le numérique a pu
apporter dans la lutte contre les pénis
aujourd'hui notre stratégie testée
alerté protégée repose ainsi sur des
outils numériques complémentaires
permettant à tous les autres les
citoyens détracteurs de leur santé je
pense à des outils comme la carte
graphie des laboratoires de santé sur
santé.fr
je pense à des outils que dont vous avez
l'occasion de débattre qui servent de
support aux brigade sanitaires je pense
à des outils d'information dans ce
contexte là stop covid contribue à
stopper ou en tout cas
doit contribuer à stopper les chaînes de
contamination
et renvoyer vers d'autres outils tels
que mes conseils coïdes qui permettent à
tous de connaître les bons gestes à
adopter et de se protéger au mieux
le deuxième principe qui nous est guidé
était celui de la transparence et de la
concertation
je crois que dès le début au sujet de
cette application le débat public a été
important
et qui nous a toujours paru important à
la fois de développer
cette application en toute transparence
quant aux principes qui l'ont guidé
quant aux statistiques qui
l'accompagnent on y reviendra peut-être
et quant à l'association des différentes
parties prenantes je rappelle quelques
Jalles en clés de la démarche
l'association de la CNIL qui a été
saisie pour avia deux reprises en avril
et en mai et qui a pu diligenter tous
les audits nécessaires au mois de juin
2020 donc il a été en capacité d'ouvrir
le capot si je peux me permettre cette
comparaison la consultation du Parlement
qui a été amenée à voter suite à un
débat sur le fondement de l'articles
50-1 de la Constitution du 4 octobre
1958 j'ai moi-même été au-dessiné par la
commission des lois au Sénat et j'ai
proposé à plusieurs reprises à
l'ensemble des groupes parlementaires
des échanges sur cette application en
amont du débat
la prise en compte des différents avis
qu'il s'agisse du conseil scientifique
mais aussi du Conseil National du
Numérique la vie concurrente également
le Conseil national de l'Ordre de
médecin et la colonie nationale de
médecine
la concertation également avec les
associations d'élus notamment les
associations d'élus avant le déploiement
et la publication s'agissant de la
transparence du l'intégralité du code
source en mai 2020 en amont du débat au
Parlement
le troisième principe est je pense qu'il
est absolument essentiel
elle a été toujours inscrire le
déploiement de stop covid dans le cadre
réglementaire et de valeur qui est le
nôtre
nous avons fait ainsi le choix d'une
application qui s'agit de préciser de
relève pas d'un cadre juridique
d'exception puisqu'elle est nativement
conforme au rgpd d'ailleurs l'acné la
plus confirmée que c'était le cas début
septembre
nous avons fait aussi le choix
d'ailleurs appelé de leurs vœux par
nombre de sénateurs au moment du débat
d'une application souveraine ce point a
pu faire débat
mais je pense que nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir le retour d'expérience ne
peut que nous conforter dans ce choix
certes et j'imagine que c'est un poids
dans nos discutons nous ne faisons pas
partie du cadre d'interopérabilité des
applications européennes
mais nous avons en France une
application dans le fonctionnement est
très satisfaisant et qui n'a rien à
envier techniquement aux applications
fonctionnant avec la solution mise en
place par Apple et Google
elle n'a rien à envier techniquement
elle l'a probablement à envier on aura
l'occasion peut-être d'y revenir en
termes de sécurité des données
et en termes de transparence compte tenu
de ces caractéristiques techniques
je rappelle les chiffres puisque
j'imagine que vous intéresse
à ce jour d'après les informations dont
nous disposons l'application stop covid
a été installé plus de 2,6 millions de
fois depuis son lancement
7969 personnes ce sont déclarées comme
ayant été testés positives c'est-à-dire
qu'elles ont flashé le code qu'il aurait
été transmis suite aux résultats de leur
test et 472 notifications ont été émises
je pense que nous sommes tous d'accord
pour dire qu'il y a un vrai enjeu
d'adoption autour de l'application je
pense non l'occasion d'y revenir
mais ce qui me semble intéressant dans
ces chiffres notamment au travers du
fait que 8000 personnes à peu près ont
flashé leur QR code dans l'application
c'est que
le potentiel de cette application reste
entier si nous arrivons à le redéployer
c'est d'autant plus intéressant que
beaucoup de personnes se déclarent dans
l'application comparativement aux autres
pays y compris à l'Allemagne
et que la dynamique d'utilisation suit
celle de l'épidémie
c'est important également de rappeler le
choix technologique qui a été fait
puisque le choix de la souveraineté nous
permet aussi d'avoir la maîtrise totale
à la fois des traitements de données qui
sont effectués mais aussi des modèles de
santé qui sont sous-jacents sous-jacents
à cette application
et je crois que vous avez eu l'occasion
de d'additionner Bruno sportifs je veux
également rappeler
que cette application est le fruit d'une
mobilisation exceptionnelle d'acteurs
français public et privé que je tiens à
recaler
et que peu de pays auraient eu la
capacité de mener un tel projet de
manière autonome
je suis maintenant disposé à répondre à
toutes vos questions merci Monsieur
monsieur ministre avant de donner la
parole aux rapporteur deux petites
questions taquines de ma part
la première
une seule qui est finalement une seule
question de taquine de ma part est-ce
que votre monde connecté à ressenti une
augmentation de votre rythme cardiaque
lorsque le Premier ministre a annoncé
qu'il n'avait pas enregistré
l'application covid
je ne peux pas répondre à votre question
monsieur le Président parce que je n'ai
pas de monde connecté
que la montre que je porte est une Casio
achetée à 25 euros
qui date je pense de la début des années
80 et donc il m'est impossible de
répondre à votre question d'accord je
passe la parole rapporteur madame de
roche
merci
moi je non
plus du tout donc je n'ai même pas une
demande non française comme c'est le
ministre
mais moi j'avais une question vous nous
expliquer en effet que ça immobilisé
beaucoup de monde
quand vous voulez avoir une souveraineté
ce qu'on peut entendre et sur quoi en
effet ça avait été une de nos deux
demandes mais comment vous expliquer
alors le relatif encore c'est gentil
dans un relatif échec du dispositif moi
je suis correcte je ne sais pas quand le
Premier ministre covid sur mon iphone
donc tout va bien mais quand vous
expliquez cette faible mobilisation par
rapport par exemple à l'Allemagne qui a
d'autres systèmes est-ce qu'on n'a pas
fait quelque chose justement de trop
trop spécifique et qui fait que que ça
ne fonctionne pas en nombre de
personnes qui l'ont téléchargé ou est-ce
que la communication a été mauvaise
comment vous expliquer ce parce que les
chiffres sont quand même là donc comment
vous l'expliquer
alors est-ce que vous souhaitez que je
revienne sur pourquoi nous avons fait le
choix de cette architecture technique
peut-être que ça peut être utile à ce
niveau du débat donc ça nécessite de
rentrer un peu dans le détail de
l'archite des deux architectures
techniques proposées je rappelle
d'ailleurs qu'à l'origine le projet
français est un projet franco-allemand
enfin Franco Germano britannique avec la
même estimation de l'ensemble de ces
trois pays mais d'autres pays autour du
monde
qui est que il y a deux modèles qui
s'opposent dans la dans la manière dont
on conçoit les applications de contact
Racing qui sont le modèle centralisé et
le modèle décentralisé et de termes
étant un peu questionnable mais c'est le
terme qui convient d'employés
comment marche un modèle
décentralisé pardon d'entrer dans la
technique mais c'est important de
comprendre pourquoi nous avons fait ces
choix là
dans les deux cas
lorsque je me promène et que je vous
rencontre Monsieur le Président à moins
d'un mètre plus de 15 minutes le fait si
vous nous avons tous les deux
l'application
chacun de nos téléphones enregistre le
fait que nous sommes croisés sur le
téléphone
dans le modèle
centralisé il existe un serveur central
et si jamais je me
identifie comme étant positif alors
l'ensemble des crypto identifiants que
j'ai enregistré sur mon téléphone
remonte sur le serveur central
et tous les téléphones je caricature un
peu mais c'est cela chaque jour ou
plusieurs fois par jour vont vérifier
qu'ils sont sur le serveur central
cet architecture a un avantage c'est que
vous comprenez que existe sur le serveur
central uniquement les identifiants ou
les crypto identifiants des gens qui
sont des contacts gens malades donc il
n'existent nulle part
de liste de crypto identifiants de gens
malades
premier élément
comment marche un système décentralisé
un système décentralisé à chaque fois
donc nous enregistrons chacun nos nos
crypto identifiants respectifs si moi je
me déclare
j'envoie mon identifiant
sur un serveur central qui le redisent
pas sur votre téléphone et donc dans un
système décentralisé
la liste des crypto identifiants de tous
les gens malades non seulement et
disponibles sur le quasiment de manière
très accessible sur Internet et en plus
elle va sur tous les téléphones
c'est ce qui a conduit l'Agence
nationale de la sécurité du système
d'information mais d'ailleurs d'accord
en cela avec ces homologues britanniques
et
allemande a considérer que en termes de
protection de la vie privée
la solution centralisée était plus
protectrice que la solution
décentralisée
et d'ailleurs ces craintes se sont
révélées fondées aujourd'hui sur les
applications européennes
si vous êtes un peu malin vous pouvez
avoir accès à l'ensemble des crypto
identifiants des gens qui se sont
déclarés malades en Europe
cette liste est facilement accessible et
avec ce qui s'appelle un sniffeur donc
la capacité à récupérer
votre ce que vous émettez comme crypto
identifiant je peux si je suis un
employeur mettre un portique à l'entrée
de mon entreprise et savoir si un de mes
employés est lequel est dans la liste
des gens malades donc c'est possiblement
ré-identifiant ces éléments je vous les
ai exposé ici vous trouverez dans les
débats académiques et techniques
notamment portées par certains de l'EPFL
qui sont ceux-là même qui
est l'institution même qui avait poussé
la solution décentralisée l'ensemble des
papiers techniques qui expliquent ce que
je viens de vous expliquer
la solution centralisée
elle ne permet jamais de ré-identifier
quelqu'un de malade
par ailleurs et donc pour des raisons il
y a une première ion qui est une région
de sécurité
de sécurité et de sécurité de la vie
privée
un des reproches qui était faite à la
solution centralisée et qui a un serveur
central et que donc un état mal est
unionné
ou peu démocratique pourrait se servir
de se servir central pour
surveiller ses citoyens si on va un peu
vite nous avons considéré que un
l'ensemble de la transparence sur les
éléments de code sur l'accès aux
serveurs central pour la CNIL et pour la
commission de surveillance et le fait
que nous étions quand même dans un état
démocratique avec une capacité de
contre-pouvoir
de la CNIL et du comité de surveillance
qui a été voté par l'assemblée par le
Sénat garantissait aux Français
au-delà de leur confiance dans le
gouvernement ce qui se passait
premièrement deuxième élément pourquoi
qui est un élément sanitaire et qui ont
conduit à l'origine
des Anglais les Allemands et les
Français à choisir la solution
centralisée vous avez aujourd'hui
15 millions peut-être 16 millions de
Britanniques qui ont une application sur
leur téléphone
vous avez je pense 18 millions
d'Allemands qui ont téléchargé
l'application vous avez un peu moins de
je l'ai dit de enfin 2,6 2,7 millions
français qui l'ont téléchargé
chez nous vous savez qu'il y a eu 99
significations 9000 codes qui ont été
scannés et 470 12 notifications qui ont
été reçus
les Allemands les anglaises sont
incapables incapables de vous dire
combien de notifications ont été reçues
incapables
pour une raison simple c'est que
l'ensemble de l'architecture est dans
les mains d'Apple et de Google
c'est que la CNIL allemande ou la CNIL
anglaise et pas capable
d'aller
Apple alto vérifier ce qui se passe sur
les serveurs
et donc je vais venir sur le sujet je ne
dis pas que le sujet de l'application
française est un succès
pardon non excusez-moi donc non parce
que ce que je dis c'est que nous on sait
ce qui se passe et on sait que ça marche
mal
les Allemands les Anglais ils savent
qu'il y a beaucoup d'applications qui
ont été téléchargées ne savent rien de
ce qui se passe
et ils ne savent même pas si ça marche
d'ailleurs je vous renvoie un article du
Monde sur ce sujet qui explique très
précisément les Allemands ne sont pas
capables de savoir combien de gens ont
été notifiés et donc c'est pour ça que
je répète aujourd'hui et je et je
l'assume vraiment c'est que je pense que
ce choix technique était bon
la question que vous posez madame la
sénatrice c'est est-ce que ce choix
technique a pu influencer
l'adoption ou pas des Français mon avis
personnel c'est plutôt que non et quand
on regarde les études il est c'est
plutôt confirmé aujourd'hui je ne sais
pas pour dire réellement le fond de la
pensée expliquer complètement pourquoi
cette application n'est pas
suffisamment téléchargé je pense que
nous sommes à la croisée de plusieurs
éléments mais ce que l'on comprend dans
les études quali qui ont été menées
c'est que le vrai sujet c'est que les
Français ne comprennent pas l'intérêt
qu'ils ont
personnel à télécharger stop covid et
que vient ensuite se surajouter vient
ensuite se surajouter des craintes sur
les données ou en tout cas une
incompréhension globale de comment se
passe sur cette application
je pense aussi qu'il y a probablement
des dimensions culturelles qui via
probablement de dimensions de timing
c'est-à-dire que les Anglais
ressortent leur application au moment
d'un reconfinement ou en tout cas au
moment où la peur remonte
nous nous avons sorti notre application
à un moment ou en fait on pensait que
c'était fini le caricature un peu mais
nous avons déconfiné
c'est impossible de refaire l'histoire
maintenant peut-être que effectivement
le fait de lancer un moment où en fait
les barres ferment on a peur qu'on
associabilité les Anglais ont interdit
les rencontres à plus de 6 personnes et
on se rend compte que ça va durer
six mois un an un an et demi alors il y
a un effet de traction sur l'application
qui est supérieure sans doute aussi
le gouvernement moi-même avons-nous été
insuffisamment pédagogique dans
l'explication de à quoi sert cette
application ce qu'elle protège etc etc
vraiment je reviens sur les sondages
qualitatifs qui montrent que les gens ne
comprennent pas quel est leur intérêt
et donc je pense que il y a une
conjonction d'éléments qui font que
cette application est insuffisamment
malheureusement en téléchargée je
voudrais juste élargir la focale il y a
un succès de l'application en
téléchargement parce encore une fois on
ne sait pas s'en impact sanitaire en
Allemagne et en Grande-Bretagne en
Suisse aussi je crois dans l'ensemble
des autres pays
c'est un échec parfois un peu moins
problématique mais c'est un échec
et donc la réussite des applications de
contact Racing
et plus l'exception que la règle cela ne
doit pas nous absoudre de l'intérêt de
cette application et de faire notre
propre introspection sur pourquoi ça n'a
pas marché mais
il ne faut pas que l'arbre anglais et
allemand cache la forêt du fait que en
fait ces applications ont du mal partout
en Europe je dis partout en Europe parce
que à part Singapour c'est difficile de
comparer les applications numériques qui
ont été déployées en Corée du Sud en
Chine etc qui n'ont absolument rien à
voir en termes de protection de la vie
privée et par ailleurs les cultures sont
très différentes
merci Madame vermeiller
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre tout d'abord une j'aimerais une
précision vous évaluer à 26 27 de
téléchargement actuels en France le 22
septembre lors d'une audition de la
commission d'enquête Bruno sportif PDG
d'ingria
nous a dit que 2 millions 5
d'applications avaient été téléchargées
un million désinstallés
puis 300 000 réinstallés
si je compte bien ça fait un million 8
aujourd'hui ça fait pas 2 millions 6
est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer l'écart
ensuite monsieur le ministre le 23 mai
lors d'une conférence sur Stop covid
vous avez déclaré qu'il serait normal
que nous puissions lancer un appel
d'offres afin d'avoir un choix plus
large avec les spécifications
qui permettront à d'autres potentiels
acteurs de s'impliquer dans le projet
pour gérer et stocker les données de
santé au sein de la plateforme
technologique française du Hells data
hub pourtant l'État a fait le choix de
la société américaine Microsoft pour
assurer l'hébergement des données de
santé des Français ce choix a été fait
sans appel d'offres et avec des risques
de transfert de données aux États-Unis
donc je voudrais vous demander quand
sera programmé l'appel d'offres qui
permettra à des entreprises européennes
de participer à l'hébergement des
données de santé des Français et
justement puisque on évoque
l'échec relatif de stop covid est-ce que
vous pensez pas qu'il y ait un lien
entre les réserves que suscitent l'écho
du else dataeb et du coup le peu de
chargement de stop covid en France merci
alors sur le chiffre que j'ai donné
c'était un chiffre de téléchargement
donc c'est un chiffre brut je vous
confirme je vous reprécisera les
chiffres que on est donc entre 2,6 et
2,7 millions de téléchargements brut et
que la désinstallation je crois est un
peu au dessus de 1 million maintenant on
doit être un million 100000 mais donc
c'est un chiffre brut
premier élément sur le deuxième élément
d'abord sur la comparaison entre stop
covid et le réalisateur
je pense que
alors je vais revenir ensuite sur
pourquoi est-ce que nous avons fait le
choix enfin pourquoi il a été fait le
choix de Microsoft à l'époque par les
équipes du réalisateur mais
c'est
si nous avions choisi de passer par
appel Google
je pense que les éléments que vous
évoquez serait aujourd'hui les éléments
du débat c'est à dire que
ça n'aurait certainement pas facilité
l'adoption par les Français et que ce
sur quoi vous m'intéresseriez
aujourd'hui c'est mais pourquoi
êtes-vous passé par une solution
américaine pour stocker les données de
santé des Français et vous auriez
d'ailleurs s'agissant des éléments que
nous pouvions développer nous-mêmes
puisque nous l'avons montré
probablement raison sur la question de
les atomes je pense qu'il faut
se remettre dans le dilemme qui a été
celui de l'époque qui était je crois en
en 2018 la présidente de la République
annonce que nous voulons accélérer sur
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle pour faire progresser la
santé pour faire progresser
la recherche française en matière
de santé et de données de santé à ce
moment-là a décidé d'être lancé
l'entrepôt des données de santé
autrement appelé
pour lequel une consultation d'acteurs
de 19 facteurs dans les Français est mis
en place
avec un certain nombre d'éléments du
cahier des charges
avec une volonté qui est de démarrer
très vite
qui est de démarrer très vite parce que
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que nous
voulons profiter de la dynamique autour
de ce sujet et par ailleurs il y a une
compétition mondiale extrêmement forte
sur l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle dans la santé
le seul capable de répondre aux
prérequis au moment où la consultation
est faite
ces Microsoft
et donc je rappelle juste un chiffre
qui doit toujours nous faire réfléchir
mais qui est le fruit de décision enfin
en tout cas de politique industrielle
depuis très longtemps chaque année
Amazon investit 22 milliards de dollars
dans la recherche et développement
chaque année la somme dépensée par
l'ensemble de la France publique privée
dans tous les domaines
de recherche et développement confondus
ça doit être entre 60 et 70 milliards de
d'euros
et dans le Cloud ça doit être moins d'un
milliard
et donc il y a des domaines notamment
dans l'intelligence artificielle ou les
Américains ont une avance que nous ne
pouvons pas nier ça ne veut pas dire que
il n'y a pas des domaines dans le cloud
dans lequel nous sommes forts et ça ne
veut pas dire que notre objectif ne doit
pas être de faire en sorte de faire
émerger un acteur français en tout cas
dans la consultation qui est faite à
l'époque sur les 19 dans plusieurs
Français pas seulement OVH mais d'autres
ce qui est
Microsoft est le mieux 10 ans et donc un
choix est fait qui est de dire nous
partons
enfin ce qui est le choix d'ailleurs du
ministère de la santé mais dire nous
partons avec Microsoft pour avoir très
vite des applications et d'ailleurs
pendant la crise du covid
le réalisateur a été très utile pour
travailler sur des sujets d'interaction
médicamenteuse et des sujets de
comorbidité facteurs de comorbidité
aurions-nous été presse il nous avions
dû attendre un an ou deux ans et choisir
un fournisseur français
je le dis honnêtement c'est très
questionnable
et donc d'une certaine manière
il y a un choix ontologique à faire
en tout cas le choix a été fait de
partir sur pour le début sur cette
plateforme et avec dans le cadre
juridique
de l'époque toutes les garanties qui
étaient prises
ce que j'ai dit lors de la conférence de
presse c'est que je souhaitais que nous
puissions
refaire un appel d'offre puisque il
était très clair dans la décision qui a
été prise que c'était que pour une phase
de démarrage pour faire en sorte que
nous allions vers
des fournisseurs enfin de pouvoir ouvrir
la compétition et en tout cas faire une
compétition ouverte
mais je vais aller un peu plus loin
c'est que il y a une décision qui a été
prise par la Cour de justice européenne
avec la validation du pravity SHIELD il
y a quelques semaines au début de l'été
et que ce à quoi nous travaillons
aujourd'hui avec Olivier Véran
suite à cette modification et cette
interprétation de la cgue qui est un
coup de tonnerre dans le domaine des
gestion des données sensibles
c'est au transfert du réalisateur sur
des plateformes françaises
ou en tout cas européenne
parce que d'abord le contexte juridique
a complètement changé mais
cela
mais une exigence et sur nous et
d'ailleurs sur les parlementaires aussi
parce que investir
dans une infrastructure de cloud
qui soit au niveau de compétitivité de
celle des Américains des Chinois ça vaut
très très cher et donc
il faut qu'on ait les la conséquence de
nos de nos choix
souverains donc c'est les discussions
que nous aurons nous avons actuellement
notamment au niveau du président de la
chasselière des discussions avec nos
partenaires allemands sur ce sujet mais
il faut bien être conscient que ne vont
pas totalement la même capacité
technologique qu'aujourd'hui y compris
pour traiter des données de santé mais
voilà compte tenu de la validation de la
richrems 2 et de l'invalidation du
premier psychique par la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne nous travaillons
la transférer ces données sur des
fournisseurs de Cloud européens
merci monsieur jaumier
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour vos
explications techniques qui sont qui
sont tout à fait intéressantes mais la
principale question qui se pose à nous
quand même c'est de comprendre pourquoi
65 millions de Français ne veulent pas
télécharger et utiliser cet outil c'est
quand même ça qui nous qui nous
préoccupe parce que je pense que on peut
partager la conviction d'une utilité de
ce type d'outils dans la stratégie de
traçage et donc après de rupture des
chaînes de transmission alors vous avez
vous avez évoqué quelques éléments vous
allez dire on a lancé l'application à un
moment ou au fond on se disait bon bah
c'est terminé enfin on sortait bon
donc j'aimerais savoir moi parce que
depuis 10-15 jours là la préoccupation
remonte et de façon forte on ferme des
bas on ferme des restaurants et bon tout
le monde porte un masque de façon
beaucoup plus stricte est-ce que depuis
dix qu'un jour vous avez constaté une
hausse significative et importante
de téléchargements de l'application
par ailleurs entendez j'ai pas fini ouh
là là ne vous pressez pas
par ailleurs
quand on veut que les gens utilisent une
application numérique on sait tous et
vous l'avez évoqué les craintes que ça
que ça soulève on répond aux craintes
avec des éléments objectifs vous les
avez assez bien exposés et puis on
répond aux craintes d'une population par
la confiance
au mois de mars avril les enquêtes
d'opinion indiquaient un soutien très
majoritaire on peut même dire massif des
Français aux mesures qui étaient prises
par le gouvernement pour lutter contre
l'épidémie le confinement je crois à
recueilli jusqu'à 93% d'opinion
favorables dans la population j'ai
jamais vu
les enquêtes d'opinion se sont dégradées
au fil des semaines et des mois et des
différents éléments on va pas revenir
dessus c'est pas l'objet aujourd'hui
mais actuellement les mesures sont très
majoritairement en général rejetées par
la population ce qui est inquiétant
comment dans ce contexte de défiance
vis-à-vis
des décisions du gouvernement
pensez-vous pouvoir
restaurer l'adhésion et la crédibilité à
un dispositif numérique proposé par le
gouvernement et c'est une question
absolument fondamentale comment est-ce
que on va continuer comme ça est-ce que
vous avez réfléchi à d'autres pistes
pour sortir de ce
de ce guêpier là et je crois que enfin
vous avez tout à fait légitimement
esquiver la question du président Milon
qui n'était pas taquine qui était
extrêmement importante parce que la
parole soit on estime que la parole des
gouvernants et des ministres n'a pas
d'importance et du premier d'entre eux
soit si elle en a
elle signe la qualité du lien entre les
gouvernants et la population et donc
c'est une interrogation qui est vraiment
centrale et ma dernière question très
précise à ce jour quel est le coût de
l'application stop covid je vous
remercie
alors
avant nous constater une augmentation
des téléchargements légères
aujourd'hui nous sommes entre 6 et 10
000 téléchargements par jour
si entre 6 et 10.000
pardon excusez-moi c'est je pense c'est
pas du masque mais
donc nous sommes entre 6 et 10000
téléchargements par jour ce qui est un
peu plus que ce qui était avant la crise
mais là où je vous rejoins c'est que
nous n'atteindrons pas 65 millions de
Français d'ailleurs nous aurions du mal
à atteindre 65 millions de Français
compte tenu de l'équipement smartphone
mais
oui c'est insuffisant
sur la question de
la confiance
et sans répondre à la question plus
essentielle de la confiance dans les
gouvernements la gestion de la crise etc
que je laisserai plutôt à Olivier Véran
quoi que vous avez je crois déjà
c'est vrai mais il m'est difficile de
voilà de répondre sur des questions
politiques sanitaires
la confiance et je vais me laisser une
question qui s'adresse à tout
gouvernance et c'est vrai mais je peux
si je peux vous répondre je ne vois pas
de corrélation entre le taux de
téléchargement en Europe et la confiance
dans les gouvernements
je pense que ça serait un sujet que nous
emmènera c'est moi je pense que le sujet
de la confiance dans la démocratie dans
les corps intermédiaires qu'ils soient
politiques institutionnels médiatique
est un énorme sujet que la crise
actuelle que nous traversons
est une crise qui peut avoir des
répercussions démocratiques eu égard à
ces questions de confiance eu égard aux
tensions qu'elle ainsi dans la société
qui sont majeur
et que évidemment cette question est au
cœur dans le cadre de des relations
entre les gouvernants et les administrés
dans le cadre d'une épidémie qui va
durer mais
s'agissant de l'application stop covid
et de ses 6000 enfin des applications
similaires je ne vois pas de corrélation
entre la confiance dans les
gouvernements et l'adhésion voilà la
question que vous posez qui fait l'objet
de réflexion intense chez nous en ce
moment c'est
comment relancer ou comment donner une
deuxième chance à ce stop covid
d'abord et malheureusement
je pense que nous ne sommes pas une
semaine près
compte tenu de la durée prévisible de
l'épidémie et donc nous y travaillons
nous y réfléchissons nous regardons ce
qui s'est passé en Angleterre c'est
assez intéressant l'exemple anglais
parce que l'application n'est pas
totalement la même dans ses
fonctionnalités que celle de
l'application allemande qui est très
proche de l'application française il y a
plus d'informations
une interconnexion plus forte avec le
système des bars et restaurants est-ce
que ça justifie l'intérêt pour
l'application je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas
on cherche à en savoir plus d'ailleurs
en lien avec nos homologues on cherche à
mieux comprendre
ce qui se passe
je pense que par ailleurs
si nous voulons relancer l'application
nous avons besoin de trouver des relais
et des alliés
c'est-à-dire que compte tenu de ce que
vous dites avec lequel je suis assez en
accord c'est à dire que la parole des
gouvernants quel qu'il soit
souffre d'un manque de crédibilité ou
d'un manque de confiance actuellement
mais quel qu'il soit partout dans le
monde nous avons besoin que si les
professions médicales
estiment que c'est utile
alors elles doivent le dire les
épidémies ont dit le Conseil
Scientifique l'a dit mais on a besoin
que les médecins généralistes que les
professeurs d'universités nous aident
ils pensent que c'est utile pour
maîtriser l'épidémie c'est à eux d'en
faire le choix c'est pas du tout voilà
si des responsables de café hôtel
restaurant estime que quelque chose qui
aidera à ne pas refermer les
établissements du public alors il faut
qu'il nous aide à ce que les gens
téléchargent ou activent covid puisque
on a aussi ce problème là c'est que les
gens le téléchargent mais ne savent pas
que quand on ferme l'application
n'est plus utile et donc
on va vivre avec ce virus pendant
longtemps si collectivement on estime
que
c'est un outil utile alors je pense
qu'il faut que ce soit un combat
collectif parce que si on veut renverser
un outil qui est insuffisamment bien
parti pour le dire avec des mots un peu
euphémisés alors on a besoin que ce soit
un une manœuvre collective je remarque
mais je n'ai pas vérifié l'information
ce que m'a dit un journaliste italien
mardi dernier puisque l'application
octalienne immuni qui a été téléchargée
plus que l'application française mais
insuffisamment là encore pour que ce
soit
utile
il m'a dit que les journaux de son pays
c'est un journaliste qui me disait ça
c'était mobilisé pour offrir au
gouvernement une page de publicité pour
faire la promotion de l'application
immuni parce qu'il considérait que cette
utile je ne fais pas du tout un appel
mais je pense que si on veut on
considère collectivement que ce stop
covid est utile alors il faut que ce
soit un mouvement collectif et que
la parole politique n'étant plus tout le
temps performatique ce n'est pas parce
que le ministre de la Santé qui fait sa
part du travail en le rappelant
systématiquement des systématiquement
cette utile télécharger stop covid quand
bout de chaîne
les jeunes les personnes âgées
les personnes concernées ou qui vont
dans les bars et les restos vont aller
sur leur App Store ou sur leur Play
Store télécharger l'application
s'agissant de la déclaration du Premier
ministre
je pense qu'il a été clair c'est à dire
que
et d'ailleurs c'est un petit sujet
auprès de stopper également on remarque
que les gens ne comprennent pas
forcément à quoi sert stop covid quand
il porte un masque
quand ils sont seuls dans leur bureau ou
à deux ou trois personnes qui le
connaissent et qu'il retrouveront un
manquablement
ce qui est vrai c'est que stop covid est
particulièrement utile quand vous allez
dans un bar dans un restaurant quand
vous faites
des soirées entre amis que vous n'avez
pas le droit de faire mais on sait que
ça va se passer quand même que les gens
ne portent pas de masque
et que vous ne savez pas forcément qui
est à côté de vous
et que vous ne retrouverez pas c'est que
les brigades sanitaires ne retrouveront
pas
ces cas de figure le Premier ministre
les rencontres assez peu et donc c'est
ce qu'il a ici d'expliquer je comprends
qu'on se concentre sur sa déclaration
mais c'est aussi ça que je pense à quoi
nous devons travailler qui est de
bien rappeler à quelles occasions stop
covid est utile et à quelle occasion
réactiver son application quand on l'a
si on pouvait à chaque fois qu'on entre
dans un restaurant réactivé
l'application je pense que ce serait
très utile mais il faut que on en soit
conscient que les opérateurs que les
restaurateurs nous aident à le rappeler
et ça nous aidera à éviter de prendre
les mesures que nous sommes forcés de
prendre
sur la question du coup alors
j'ai pensé bien avoir le question mais
le sujet étant un peu complexe
alors je ne voudrais pas vous dire de
bêtises
d'accord alors juste rappeler peut-être
le cadre
juridique dans lequel cela se déploie
alors d'abord préciser que l'État
français n'a rien payé jusqu'au 2 juin
2020 et donc dans toute la phase de
développement 8 avril de juin
l'État français n'a rien payé d'ailleurs
que j'avais précisé lors de mon passage
dans les différentes commissions du
Sénat et en séance publique je rappelle
que pour le même travail les Allemands
ont payé 20 millions d'euros que les
Anglais ont payé quelques millions de
livres je ne sais plus combien et que
chaque pays a payé
ensuite
à partir du 2 janvier 2 juin 2020
les personnes impliquées sont le
ministère de la Santé qui est le premier
qui est en première ligne puisqu'il est
responsable de traitement de
l'application et financeur du projet
il y a un accord cadre d'assistance à
maîtrise d'oeuvre pour le déploiement
lymphogérance et l'exploitation
l'hébergement le maintien incondition
opérationnel de sécurité le support
utilisateur l'animation du déploiement
et des usages et la maintenance
évolutive de l'application stop covid
passer entre la direction générale de la
santé et INRIA et donc c'est dans ce
cadre contractuel là que les
l'équipe projet stop covid fonctionne
avec un accord de consortium entre les
acteurs privés engagés dans le
déploiement de l'application à savoir
outside associé qui était filiale de
Dassault Systèmes Capgemini Luna be
orange et l'entreprise withing qui est
spécialiste des objets connectés
alors la manière dont nous travaillons à
ce stade
c'est que il ne met pas possible de vous
donner un chiffre au réel je ne peux
vous donner que les autorisations
plafond qui ont été donnés dans le cadre
du marché car à ce stade il y a eu des
avances mais il n'y a pas eu de
facturation au réel donc je peux vous
donner des plafonds je précise bien que
ce sont des plafonds car il est comme
tout plafond nous les avons pensé en
étant en gardant une marge très
importante
afin de faire en sorte que on puisse
tirer sur le sujet si nous en avions
besoin par exemple si nous devions
réfléchir à déployer de nouvelles
fonctionnalités là le coût serait
probablement supérieur il faudrait qu'on
reste dans le cadre des plafonds donc on
sera Infiné à un quart ou la moitié des
plafonds mais je vous donne les plafonds
puisque c'est la question que vous me
posez
alors sur la période des quatre premiers
mois d'exploitation c'est-à-dire du 2
juin 2020 au 31 septembre
2020 le plafond pour cette période
totale et de 26000 euros
à partir pardon mais je suis pas certain
donc pardon oui donc c'est 206000 euros
pour cette période là au total
et les premières factures sont
d'ailleurs émises en octobre pour les
premiers mois d'exploitation
pardon attendez juste pose une question
parce que je suis pas certain de
comprendre
vous pouvez répondre par écrit ce que je
vous propose en fait parce que je viens
de me tromper dans les chiffres donc ce
n'est pas une très bonne chose
le plafond pardon sur cette période est
de 86000 euros par mois donc vous voyez
c'est je me suis trompé donc quels sont
les chiffres qu'il faut retenir
en gros à ce stade le plafond est
environ de 100.000 euros par mois
et donc c'est un plafond
avec jusqu'ici jusque fin octobre
Capgemini qui est le chef maître
d'oeuvre du projet travail gratuitement
à partir de fin de la fin octobre nous
aurons nous avons lancé un appel
d'offres qui permettra de faire en sorte
de désigner selon des règles de marché
public un nouveau chef de projet et donc
ce montant plafond va augmenter
il va pas exploser mais il va augmenter
donc il va probablement passer autour de
200 de 200000 euros
je veux juste faire que pour vous donner
une idée un comparatif avec la situation
allemande
pour nous ça a été un développement à
zéro euro
et
[Musique]
un coup de fonctionnement enfin un coup
de d'entretien et de suivi qui est entre
100 et 200000 euros plafond par an par
mois les Allemands c'est 20 millions
d'euros de développement 3 millions
d'euros par mois les chiffres sont
publics
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est capable de
faire ça justement parce que toute une
partie de la maîtrise d'oeuvre et la
maîtrise d'ouvrage est assurée par INRIA
et que nous avons le savoir-faire le
choix qui a été celui des Allemands a
été de faire sous-traiter par SAP et par
Deutsche Telecom la production des
éléments je suis désolé de pas pouvoir
extrêmement plus précis mais les
éléments étant à tiroir ce que je me
propose c'est de vous répondre
précisément par écrit
ça y est c'est parti j'ai une deux trois
quatre cinq collègues inscrits
madame de roche qui souhaitait reprendre
une question je voulais repartir sur des
points que vous avez évoqué lorsque vous
avez répondu à mes collègues le premier
vous nous avez bien dit et pour nous
c'est important lorsqu'on a lancé
socovite c'est parce qu'on pensait que
l'épidémie était terminée c'est ça c'est
bien deuxième point vous dites là on est
en effet le relancer
mais bon on n'est pas une semaine près
moi c'est quelque chose qui me qui me
trouve un peu parce que on est quand
même dans une situation relance des
plans blancs
avec dans des programmations
certes j'entends le délai de la semaine
mais c'est justement un peu ce qui fait
qu'on a peut-être pris du retard ça a
été de se dire on n'est pas une semaine
près et je pense que c'est là où il y a
eu ces phases de retard alors c'est
facile vous l'avez dit de refaire
l'histoire et sur une pandémie dont on
ne connaissait pas le mais je pense que
là c'est vraiment des points des points
importants et puis sur la relation
confiance et téléchargement de
l'application
il y a des pays où il y avait à la fois
la confiance et une vraie application ce
sont des cultures différentes puisqu'on
a entendu Taïwan et la Corée du la Corée
du Sud mais en Allemagne on voit bien
qu'il y avait une confiance qui est une
application alors certes elle coûte
peut-être un peu plus cher que la nôtre
mais le coût global de l'Allemagne sera
sans doute inférieur aux autres si je
mets globalement donc c'était des
remarques que je voulais faire
merci vous désirez répondre où je passe
juste ce que j'ai dit c'est que nous
avons lancé l'application un mot ou
beaucoup de Français pensaient que
l'épidémie était terminée c'est pas que
nous pensions que le pays limitée
les Français pensaient que l'épidémie
terminée et donc
une partie d'ailleurs seulement mais en
tout cas que la crainte était moins
présente qu'elle ne l'est probablement
aujourd'hui premier élément deuxième
élément
pourquoi je dis que nous ne sommes pas à
une semaine près je veux pas que vous
mépreniez sur
la les interrogations qui
nous tenaille et les évaluations de la
situation sanitaire
mais je il y a une chose dont je suis
persuadé
c'est que nous n'aurons pas
deux fois une deuxième chance
et que donc si on devait décider de
relancer stop covid nous avons intérêt à
savoir exactement ce que nous voulons
faire exactement quels sont les
modifications techniques que nous
voulons apporter et une modification
technique sur une application grand
public comme celle-ci ça prend plusieurs
semaines à développer et également
prendre en compte les retours
d'expérience des pays où ça a marché
je rappelle quand même que sur le
lancement de l'application nous étions
les premiers en Europe à le faire que
des équipes ont travaillé nuit et jour
pour être prêt pour le lancement le 2
juin le lancement de l'application et
donc bien évidemment que dès lors que le
président lui-même Olivier Véran le
Premier ministre rappelle que cette
application est utile dans la lutte
contre l'épidémie nous ne sommes pas en
train de nous tourner les pouces pour
regarder ce qui se passe mais encore une
fois
la réussite des applications c'est
l'exception en Europe c'est pas la règle
vous citez l'exemple allemand c'est un
très bon exemple effectivement à bien
des égards on aimerait être dans
l'exemple allemand
je pense que pour le coup la Corée du
Sud pour bien connaître la culture
puisque mon père est coréen c'est très
différent
je pense que c'est vraiment rien à voir
bon pardon mais donc voilà donc il faut
si nous devons relancer cette
application on peut pas se louper et
donc même si on prend le temps des
modifications techniques une semaine 10
jours je préfère que nous les prions
et que on met toutes les chances de
notre côté pour faire en sorte que ce
deuxième lancement réussisse
merci bien donc nous allons passer à
part la madame Préville merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre alors
je voudrais revenir tout d'abord sur le
manque de coordination que nous avons eu
avec les autres pays l'Union européenne
et vous demandez pourquoi ça ne marche
pas pourquoi on a loupé en fait le coche
et effectivement comme disait ma
collègue tout à l'heure il y a une
question de vitesse de réponse en fait
par rapport au phénomènes et c'est
peut-être ce qui explique que les
Britanniques et les Allemands ont
téléchargé puisque c'était disponible et
peut-être qu'ils ont eu plus confiance
que nous la question de l'efficacité et
du bilan et du coup je reste très
dubitative sur ce que vous nous avez
raconté sur le coup j'ai du mal à suivre
et à comprendre et et ensuite vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure
que les en Grande-Bretagne et en
Allemagne
il n'y avait pas vous ne les
gouvernements ne connaissaient pas le
nombre de notifications mais est-ce que
le but c'est que l'État soit au courant
qui ait eu un certain nombre de
notifications ou bien est-ce que ce qui
est important c'est que chaque personne
individuellement et ça notification et
agissent en ce sens-là donc je là aussi
je voudrais avoir votre votre opinion
là-dessus et puis enfin
parce que je reviens et j'étais déjà
interview dans le débat au Sénat c'est
l'idée qu'une solution qui soit
parfaitement anonyme n'est pas
atteignable et
juste se poser la question pour une
personne âgée pour une personne âgée qui
est seule chez elle et qui ne qui n'a
pour seul contact qu'une aide ménagère
si elle devient positive forcément elle
va se dire que c'est son aide ménagère
mais pour autant je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse affirmer que ce si elle est
tester positif ce sera forcément ça
puisqu'on sait que la livraison de de
nourriture
à domicile et que ça peut être sur un
emballage plastique puisque ça reste
plusieurs jours c'est le matériau qui
garde le plus longtemps le virus donc il
peut y avoir des fuites d'information et
moi c'est toujours le questionnement que
j'ai par rapport à ça par rapport à la
sécurité et par rapport aux quatre
particuliers et pas si particulier que
ça en fait sur les personnes qui sont
seules à domicile et qui donc on pourra
cibler et toutes les conséquences que ça
peut avoir sur quelque chose qui va un
peu contaminer la société sur
se douter ou ou sans être vraiment sûr
pouvoir dire que c'est un tel qui va
contaminer voilà je vous remercie
alors
sur le manque des coordinations avec les
autres pays de l'Union européenne
d'abord sur la vitesse de réponse nous
avons été les premiers à sortir
bien avant les Allemands et bien avant
les Anglais puisque les Anglais ne
sortent que maintenant soit 3 mois plus
tard donc la première application
disponible a été l'application française
en Europe
donc en tout cas ce n'est pas il y a
plein de raisons qui expliquent
probablement le fait que nous n'ayons
pas réussi mais en tout cas ce n'est pas
la question de la rapidité de réponse
pourquoi ne sommes-nous pas coordonnées
avec les autres pays mais parce que nous
avions un choix assez binaire soit en
choisissait de ce coordonner avec les
autres pays on avait appelé Google c'est
aussi simple que ça soit en choisissait
de passe coordonnées et on restait
souverain
honnêtement la valeur ajoutée de la
coordination avec les autres pays elle
est très limitée elle est vraie pour les
voyages internationaux mais
si j'ai besoin d'allumer demain voir mon
homologue allemand je téléchargerai
l'application allemande et ça me posera
pas beaucoup de problèmes et pour les
travailleurs transfrontaliers ils ont
deux applications ce qui ne me semble
pas totalement
diriment en termes d'expérience
utilisateur donc vraiment on a fait un
choix qui est de ne pas se coordonner
avec l'Union européenne sur ce sujet
parce que nous ne souhaitions pas
travailler avec Apple et Google
sur le nombre de notifications
je suis un peu en désaccord avec vous
parce que
quand même c'est allemand les Anglais
ils ne savent pas si ça marche
elle est très téléchargée mais ils ne
savent pas vous dire combien de
notifications ont été envoyées
c'est-à-dire que et c'est même un
problème démocratique si je peux me
permettre vous avez un processing de
données santé
personne n'est capable de vous dire ce
qui est en train de se passer je veux
dire c'est quand même pas des
entreprises qui ont un tracricore en
matière de protection de la vie privée
qui est exceptionnelle via la CNIL
allemande elle va pas ouvrir la boîte de
l'application
nous chez nous
et je suis capable de vous dire que ça
marche pas super bien parce que parce
que voilà mais si l'application
allemande il y a 17 millions de
personnes 18 millions de personnes qui
l'ont téléchargé il y a une seule
personne qui a reçu une notification
mais personne ne le saura
donc je quelque part même pour la
représentation nationale
vous avez payé une application 20
millions d'euros vous payez 3 millions
d'euros par an par mois vous savez pas
ça marche
enfin en tout cas moi je considère que
le que il y a des justifications au
choix qui a été fait par la France
je trouve ça totalement légitime de
questionner d'ailleurs ce choix mais en
tout cas c'est dans ces cadres là que
nous avons fait ce choix là sur la
question de la personne âgée seule chez
elle sur l'action de la fuite
d'information technique
nous avons pris toutes les
sécurités que nous pouvions c'est à dire
que concrètement l'ancien d'abord le
niveau de sécurité
extrêmement fort
je voilà je ne peux que vous dire cela
je ne pense mais en prix toutes les
toutes les garanties possibles
s'agissant de la personne âgée qui est
seule chez elle
mais dans le cadre des brigades
sanitaires
en fait on va aller récupérer le contact
le numéro de téléphone
donc je veux dire le sujet de
l'application et du contact Racing c'est
que
on doit remonter les chaînes de
contamination ce que vous faites à
travers cette covid c'est que si jamais
elle est prévenue qu'elle a été
contaminée d'abord il faut qu'elle est
stop covid
je suis pas certain qu'il y a énormément
de personnes âgées qui stoppent covid et
ensuite elle n'est pas elle ne sait pas
elle n'est pas capable de retracer quand
ok elle a rencontré mais s'il y a de la
rencontrer qu'une personne sur les 7
derniers jours que ce soit par les
brigades sanitaires ou de toute façon
pardon mais si elle a rencontré une
seule personne sur les 7 derniers jours
et qu'elle tombe malade
elle a une indication assez forte pour
savoir qui
oui mais c'est la même chose sur Stop
covid tu vois il y a pas de il y a pas
plus de
donc
ça change ça ne change pas grand chose à
la situation en tant que telle de
propagation de l'étude quand vous n'avez
rencontré qu'une seule personne on a
rencontré qu'une seule personne
merci Madame jasmin pour la suite
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
la ministre
ça vient d'une bonne volonté certes mais
quand on voit la réalité le succès
escompté bon on voit bien que ces
limites et là j'ai souvenir de
l'audition de votre ex collègue
porte-parole du gouvernement qui avait
parlé de la culture
scientifique des Français donc c'est
comme si les Français ont fait n'était
pas en mesure de comprendre mais si
c'était l'inverse est-ce que le niveau
de connaissance suffisant des Français
ont été suffisamment
poussé pour attirer la méfiance par
rapport à cette application donc est-ce
qu'on s'est posé la question est-ce que
nous ce qui ne se sont pas parce qu'il y
a eu aussi une certaine cacophonie un
certain moment pour le dire donc est-ce
que c'est pas la méfiance qui a suscité
ces freins et puis concernant la réponse
que vous avez donné au sénateur Joumier
qui est rapporteur concernant les coûts
on constate qu'il y a quand même une
façonardeuse je dirais de faire les
dépenses parce que vous dites avec
fierté que entre le 8 avril et le 2 juin
l'État français n'a rien payé mais
l'État français a quand même payer et là
si vous fonctionnez comme pour les
consommation je trouve que c'est quand
même dangereux parce que vous allez
après mettre en place si vous voyez que
dans l'urgence il fallait faire quelque
chose mais par rapport aux besoins
qui avait la foi dans les hôpitaux les
besoins pour soigner réellement
l'urgence c'était peut-être là donc vous
avez évidemment fait un choix mais je
crois que les soignants avaient besoin
aussi de fond donc est-ce qu'il y a
cette nécessaire de faire
dans l'immédiat cette priorité là parce
que vous voyez bien d'avoir un avril et
juin donc là est-ce que les priorités
étaient vraiment les plus pertinentes
merci monsieur le président
la question
des doutes des Français liés à la
communication autour de l'application je
ne peux que abonder dans votre sens
c'est-à-dire que oui je pense que en
partie les questionnements les
polémiques sur la question de
l'application ont pu créer de la
méfiance des Français
je ne peux que le regretter je ne peux
que constater que l'acnil est venue voir
sur pièce et sur place qu'elle a donné à
plusieurs reprises Songo pour
l'application
qu'elle a confirmé moyennant quelques
petites modifications que l'application
était conforme au rgpd en septembre
dernier
mais que effectivement les les
discussions autour de ces applications
on peut probablement créer de l'émoi
sur la question du coup pour le coup je
ne suis pas d'accord avec vous les
entreprises ont travaillé pro bono entre
le 8 avril et 2 juin 2020 je veux dire
elles l'ont fait pour une raison simple
comme beaucoup d'autres entreprises et
comme beaucoup de Français c'est
qu'elles ont considéré qu'il était leur
devoir national de mettre leur personnel
à disposition qui entre INRIA et toutes
les entreprises qui ont été remises
mises en qui ont été impliqués entre le
8 avril le 2 juin c'est plus de 200
personnes
et donc je
je veux quand même enfin
pour le coup je pense qu'il faut plutôt
les en remercier c'est-à-dire il y a
quand même une situation un peu ubuesque
qui est que des entreprises françaises
décident de mettre leur personnel à
disposition gratuitement nuit de tes
jours y compris le week-end pour aider
l'État à développer une application
et que derrière
monsieur Céline je pense que elle sert à
rien on fera les comptes à la fin comme
on dit chez moi c'est à la fin de la
foire qu'on compte les bouses donc on
verra
mais
je
donc elles sont venues elles se sont
impliquées elles ont mis du personnel à
disposition
je pense qu'il faut les en remercier
maintenant on rentre dans un process
contractuel plus normal et c'est normal
et c'est ça mais on dit dans une période
d'urgence on est dans une période où il
fallait se mobiliser elles l'ont fait
gratuitement et je pense qu'il faut les
en remercier
merci bien monsieur Savary pour la suite
oui merci moi j'avais une remarque à
faire qui veulent endroit fille de ma
collègue c'est une attrice quoi deux
fois vous nous avez dit Monsieur le
Ministre les Français ne comprennent pas
une fois vous avez dit les Français ne
comprennent pas la deuxième fois vous
les gens ne comprennent pas est-ce que
vous pensez pas que certes il y a une
défiance des Français et vis-à-vis du
monde politique tout ce constaté on est
d'accord mais on a l'impression qu'il y
a une vraie défiance du gouvernement
vis-à-vis des Français parce qu'il y a
des Français qui ont très bien compris
quoi
et cette défiance tant qui a ce climat
de défiance vous m'en excusez mais
l'autre jour on a entendu parler d'un
culturisme scientifique là c'est les
gens ne comprennent pas tant que vous
avez des relations comme ça et c'est le
médecin qui parle ça peut pas marcher
quoi les relations ne peuvent marcher
que contiennent une relation de
confiance voilà c'est comme ça que les
relations type médecin malade le malade
si la confiance dans son médecin vous
savez vous obtenez énormément de choses
il a pas confiance il va voir celui d'à
côté ouais et ben c'est le même genre je
pense que là dessus il pourrait y avoir
confiance dans le peuple et ça réglerait
les choses
deuxièmement je ferme la parenthèse mais
je vous livre mon sentiment deuxièmement
l'autre jour nous étions en réunion de
bureau ma chère collègues Catherine
Desroches
me dit en parlant de cette covid est-ce
que tout le monde a stop covid très bien
moi je dis ah non j'ai pas stop
j'avais mis cette covid parce qu'après
je me suis dit quand même ça m'étonne
que j'ai pas mis c'est pas moi qui mets
les applications c'est mon assistante
sauf que ça m'a bouffé la batterie
et donc à un moment j'ai dit stop je
m'en souvenais même plus parce que j'ai
un détail j'ai dit stop j'arrête
l'application alors depuis monsieur le
mini je mets l'application mais c'est je
vous raconte un Français moyen j'ai mis
l'application je n'ai aucune
interactivité
j'en ai discuté avec d'autres on fait
des relations avec les ARS le préfet on
en parle de stop covid qu'est-ce qui
nous dit c'est responsables il y a pas
d'interactivité on l'oublie ou bien on a
d'autres soucis donc ça fait que s'il y
avait de temps en temps un rappel vous
voyez un petit message ça se fait
quelque chose ça vous rappelle sans
arrêt que elle est branchée elle est pas
branchée attention ça monte ça descend
c'est un outil extraordinaire pour
communiquer avec les personnes et je
trouve qu'il est incomplet cet outil
c'est pour ça que vous vouliez que vous
l'ayez pas vous en souvenez même plus
arriver un certain moment alors autre
question maintenant passer ces Ré
flexions moi je souhaite qu'on aille
vers une interactivité c'est comme ça
que les applications marchent c'est pas
autrement me semble-t-il la question que
je souhaite vous poser c'est par rapport
à la Cour de justice européenne
vous avez dit que il y avait des mesures
qui étaient prises et qui est
véritablement par rapport aux acteurs
américains il y avait des problèmes de
confidentialité des données donc c'est
les pays étrangers qui vont être
davantage touchés puisqu'ils sont avec
Google etc avec Apple non avec
enfin avec les Gafa donc il va être
touché mais nous comme nous hébergeons
sous Microsoft américain on est touché
ça veut dire quoi que ces données qui
ont été hébergées par Microsoft sont les
Américains qui les possèdent nous me
semble-t-il mais vous allez répondre
peut-être que je me trompe nous nous
posons là c'est pas interactif non plus
ne possédons pas les données américaines
alors demain ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ces
données de santé qui ont été collectées
et ben qu'est-ce qu'elles vont devenir
qu'est-ce qu'elles vont devenir puisque
ces Microsoft ça pose un sérieux
problème
qu'en est-il c'est des données qui au
bout de six mois devaient être effacées
quels sont les garanties que vous avez
ou bien sont-elles perdues
définitivement parce que le jour où vous
allez couper effectivement avec
Microsoft que deviennent ces données
merci
alors monsieur le sénateur
plusieurs éléments
quand je dis les Français ne comprennent
pas ce n'est pas une qualification de ma
part c'est juste ce que nous disent les
sondages qualités que nous avons fait
auprès de gens qui n'avaient pas stable
covid pourquoi n'avez-vous pas cette
covid et les réponses majoritaires c'est
parce que je ne comprends pas quel est
mon pardon nous avons donc des sondages
qualificatifs et les réponses
majoritaires c'est parce que je ne
comprends pas quel est mon intérêt et
donc je n'ai pas d'appréciation
qualitative à porter sur la
compréhension par les Français de
l'épidémie ou pas je ne peux que
constater que quantitativement
quand on fait des études c'est ce qui
remonte donc je voilà c'est pour vous
dire qu'il n'y avait pas de
qualification de l'attitude des Français
de ma part
votre intervention sur la batterie elle
met très utile monsieur le sénateur
c'est faux et d'ailleurs vous pouvez
vous en apercevoir vous-même puisque
comme tout le monde a un Apple ou un
Samsung vous pouvez aller voir dans vos
réglages quels applications
utilisent de la batterie
et vous vous apercevrez que stop covid
même allumé toute la journée vous prend
moins de 1% de votre batterie et donc je
le dis parce que j'en profite parce que
parce que je l'ai entendu à plusieurs
reprises mais c'est faux la batterie
non mais c'est pas moi qui vous le dis
c'est votre téléphone qui vous le dit
donc
voilà donc ne croyez pas le gouvernement
mais croyez votre téléphone qui n'a
aucun intérêt à vous mentir sur ce
produit il a pas d'action dans ce top
covid 1% voilà non mais je vous le dis
je
voilà donc je
non mais non non c'est pas vrai monsieur
on me l'a fait plein de fois à chaque
fois c'est ma réponse et elle est pas
voilà donc vraiment je suis formel sur
ce sujet la batterie faux
et vraiment c'est je
serais prêt à vous croire si le
téléphone disait autre chose mais moi
aussi c'est je levais laisse toute la
journée et c'est à 1%
la question de stop covid et des outils
du gouvernement de la lutte enfin dans
notamment contact Racing etc ce n'est
pas hébergé sous une plateforme
américain le l'entrepôt des données de
santé de nous parlerons tout à l'heure
c'est un autre projet et d'ailleurs le
sujet n'est pas tant que les données
appartiennent aux Américains dans les
données n'appartiennent pas aux
Américains elles appartiennent
juridiquement aux Français mais il y a
une incertitude juridique sur la
capacité de la justice américaine à
venir saisir ses données de manière
extraterritoriale qui conduit l'Union
européenne européenne a considérer qu'il
y a un risque juridique mais aujourd'hui
elles appartiennent aux Français il n'y
a pas de demande de réduction des
Français s'agissant de stop covid en
tant que tel l'hébergeur et outkale donc
d'associ System
qui est une de nos pépites technologique
que vous connaissez j'imagine et donc
tout est hébergé chez les Français et
d'ailleurs il n'y a que des entreprises
françaises qui ont été impliquées dans
qui ont été impliqués dans le projet
stop covid donc je pense qu'il faut être
vraiment très clair là-dessus
tout dans cette covid et français et
donc nous nous avons d'ailleurs veillé
et c'était un des éléments qui étaient
importants à nos yeux je ne s'agissant
d'interprétation pour les pays qui sont
chez Apple Google de l'arrêt de la CJUE
je laisserai les pays répondre en même
madame Cohen c'est à vous
oui merci monsieur le Président
[Musique]
dans le domaine de l'interopérabilité on
distingue trois sortes de opérabilité
technique syntaxique et sémantique plus
le vocabulaire des échanges et en
général pour le médical on va choisir la
terminologie de l'OMS
or il y a une société snowmed
internationale qui a développé une
terminologie géante et multi domaine qui
a pour ambition de devenir un langage
des changes universel
effectivement il y a la gratuité de
cette licence mais la licence
s'accompagne de restriction qui font que
la terminologie est difficilement
utilisable en recherche
j'ai été moi alerté par des chercheurs
et beaucoup pensent que ce principe
provient à privatiser le bien commun
représenté par notre vocabulaire de
santé j'aimerais donc monsieur le
ministre avoir votre position sur
cette société snowman
est-ce que vous pensez malgré donc
toutes ces défiances
avoir une application plan national et
si tel est le cas qu'elle garde-fou vous
voulez mettre en place pour éviter
justement cette ce risque de
privatisation ma deuxième question c'est
concernant la souveraineté
vous avez donc au nom de la souveraineté
numérique vous avez refusé et vous
l'avez redit ici de vous appuyer sur
Apple ou Google pour l'application stop
covid c'est bien ce que vous avez
affirmé ce que vous avez redit à juste
titre et il y a par contre une autre
une autre application qui s'appelle else
data hob on vient d'en parler un petit
peu et qui finalement va voir les
données de santé
confié à Microsoft alors que plusieurs
associations de soignants
d'informaticiens de chercheurs de
participants du logiciel comme Interop
et des syndicats s'opposent à ces
choix-là donc comme il y a des
propositions d'alternatives moi je vous
demande monsieur le ministre qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de mettre en place un
grand service public des données de
santé qui associent donc les expertises
des soignants des organismes de
recherche publique et des entreprises
nationales outre le fait de garantir la
sécurité de nos données ça permettrait
également d'encourager un développement
industriel et sa participerait à une
souveraineté numérique de la France dans
le cadre évidemment de coopération
européenne et industrielle on est
vraiment là dans le sujet de là la
souveraineté numérique qui a vraiment un
lien avec ce dont on est en train de
parler sur STOP covid
sur votre première question je vous
avoue que je n'ai je ne connais pas
cette société je n'en ai jamais entendu
parler et donc je me permettrais de vous
répondre par écrit afin de vous apporter
une réponse précise sur la question du
de l'entrepôt des données de santé et de
stop covid je pense que la différence
entre stop covid et l'entrepôt des
données de santé c'est que nous sur Stop
covid nous avions la compétence à
l'instant T pour faire ce que faisait
les Américains sur l'entrepôt des
données de santé comme je l'ai évoqué
mais je ne reviendrai peut-être pas sur
le long développement que j'ai fait sur
notre volonté maintenant d'aller vers
une solution européenne à l'instant T je
le répète c'est à dire début 2018 de
mémoire
les capacités
les seuls à même de répondre à nos
nécessités pour des politiques
sanitaires étaient les Américains et
donc il y a eu ce choix qui a été fait
maintenant de l'eau a coulé sous les
ponts la juridique la jurisprudence le
cadre juridique a été significativement
modifié et donc nous allons évoluer mais
dans un sens qui est cohérent avec ce
que vous évoquiez mais il y a eu ce
choix un peu cornélien qui a dû être
fait à l'époque
c'est
le président ce que je veux être sûr de
ne pas interpréter vos propos et de bien
les entendre donc pour la première
question une réponse écrite me va bien
que je partagerai avec mes collègues
parce que j'imagine qu'ils sont aussi
intéressés mais pour la deuxième le
deuxième élément donc sur la
souveraineté numérique vous dites que
autant t il y avait pas les compétences
au niveau de la France donc vous avez
été amené à abriter donc nos données de
santé sur Microsoft mais que les choses
ont évolué et que vous réfléchissez je
le dis peut-être un peu abruptement un
peu différemment alors si j'entends vos
propos et si j'essaye de les parce que
je suis bien naturel optimiste donc
j'essaye de les pousser est-ce que ça
veut dire que parmi les alternatives que
vous envisagez
la question justement de ce ce pôle
public enfin ce service public en
quelque sorte ce grand service public de
donner de santé donc associant tous les
les soignants etc et quelque chose qui
fait partie des alternatives que vous
avez que vous allez envisager
aujourd'hui la question qui se pose est
celle de l'infrastructure
c'est à dire que l'entrepôt des données
de santé l'équipe de l'entrepôt des
notre santé la gouvernance de l'entrepôt
des années de santé c'est une équipe
publique c'est un entrepôt c'est une
gouvernance publique avec l'ensemble des
hôpitaux qui associe l'ensemble des
acteurs de la santé etc
elle utilise un outil américain mais
aujourd'hui je veux dire la volonté de
l'entrepôt des données de santé c'est
bien de laisser la gouvernance des
données de santé à la main du système de
santé français et du gouvernement
français en choisissant en ayant des
règles très claires sur la qui va
pouvoir processer les données en ayant
des règles très claires sur comment vous
pouvez accéder aux données est-ce que
vous pouvez faire tourner en choisissant
les projets les plus intéressants etc
etc mais tout ça c'est une équipe
publique avec une gouvernance publique
avec l'association des différents
hôpitaux et d'ailleurs il ne faut pas
vous imaginer aujourd'hui l'entrepôt des
données de santé comme un très grand
entrepôt dans lequel il y a tous les
données de santé des Français en fait
toutes vos données sont chacune et par
peler ce qui est d'ailleurs une des très
grosses difficultés du projet dans les
hôpitaux de chez votre médecin
généraliste chez votre laboratoire
d'expertise etc etc et ce que nous
sommes en train de faire
c'est d'interconnecter l'ensemble de ces
bases ce qui est très compliqué pour
ensuite voilà et et pour une partie
remontera dans l'interface technique que
j'évoque tout à l'heure du HDH du
réalisateur qui est sous
infrastructure américaine et c'est cela
que pour me faire bien comprendre c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure c'est
cette infrastructure technique que nous
allons faire évoluer vers un fournisseur
européen mais le reste de de la mais il
y a pas de fournisseur public
d'infrastructures madame sénatrice
[Musique]
non
la gouvernance elle est publique les
équipes elles sont publiques mais les
fournisseurs de Cloud
en fait il y a OVH il y a autre scale il
y a cequel ouais il y a ou drive c'est
toi ces entreprises privées mais il y a
pas de et puis il peut y avoir des
autres entreprises européennes mais il y
a ce sera une entreprise privée qui
viendra donner elle sera en contrat de
prestation avec
l'équipe de l'entrepôt donné de santé
mais mais il n'y a pas d'entreprise
publique qui fasse du cloud aujourd'hui
donc je peux vous garantir que il y aura
les mêmes les garanties juridiques de
process sanitaire etc sont les mêmes et
qu'elles seront publiques mais l'outil
lui sera fourni par une entreprise
privée qui ne sera plus une entreprise
dans la maison mère est aux États-Unis
pour le dire plus clairement
le président monsieur le ministre s'est
en fait un bilan à 6 mois qu'on fait
aujourd'hui et moi je suis pas du tout
technique et technicienne mais c'est un
outil pour moi un outil supplémentaire
ou complémentaire or bon à entendre et à
constater le peu d'enthousiasme des
Françaises et des Français sur cette
stop covid sur cet outil et cette
application moi j'aimerais vous poser la
question qu'est-ce que vous feriez
aujourd'hui de mieux ou de plus pour que
six mois après on en arrive pas là et
puis vous avez parlé donc de votre
volonté de développer cette application
et notamment vous avez pris l'exemple
des restaurateurs en disant que bon il
faut que ce soit un travail d'ensemble
et
de partenariat est-ce que vous avez
contacté les par exemple l'Union des
métiers
interprofessionnels de l'hôtellerie
est-ce que vous avez contacté les
associations les fédérations de
consommateurs enfin de quelle manière
vous souhaitez vous alliez davantage de
monde parce que vous le savez depuis le
début de le milieu de la semaine là chez
les restaurateurs nous nous sommes un
peu tracés mais c'est bien avec le
papier et le crayon que nous donnons nos
coordonnées donc on est très loin de
l'application stop covid
que faire de plus je bon
je pense qu'il y a des éléments qui ont
été évoqués par le sénateur dont j'ai
pas assez dit non mais qui est médecin
voilà pardon monsieur c'est le sénateur
l'idée de mettre de l'information en
interactivité que les gens se rappellent
que c'est utile d'y aller qui puisse
avoir c'est une idée sur laquelle nous
travaillons
je pense que ça ne change pas tout mais
qu'effectivement si on peut avoir des
informations simples éventuellement de
du département dans lequel on est voilà
savoir quoi faire quand on est qu'un
contact les numéros de téléphone etc
c'est une idée sur lequel nous
travaillons qui est effectivement très
intéressante et je pense que c'est c'est
effectivement une piste de travail qui
répond à d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que je
faisais le comparatif entre
l'application allemande et l'application
anglaise c'est ce que fait l'application
anglaise ce n'est pas du tout ce que
fait l'application allemande pourquoi à
l'origine nous étions partis sur quelque
chose
d'extrêmement pur quelque part pour le
dire mais du coup effectivement de peu
interactif
je vous rappelle qu'il y avait quand
même beaucoup de questions et de
psychoses autour de l'application et de
débat légitime et donc nous avions
choisi de cantonner l'application dans
son pur travail de contact Racing pour
ne pas entrer dans des débats compliqués
sur quelle information qu'on a les
mettre etc donc mais ça on peut le
changer sur la question des
restaurateurs vous aurez peut-être
remarqué que dans le protocole qui a été
négocié avec les restaurateurs
franciliens nous avons injecté la
recommandation enfin la demande de
recommander stop covid et donc ça fait
formellement partie du protocole donc
c'est ce genre d'action que je pense que
nous pouvons développer mais c'est une
chose de le mettre dans le protocole
c'est une autre chose que quand vous
arrivez dans le restaurant dans tous les
restaurants il y a un
QR code avec écrit téléchargé cet
après-midi de réactiver le donc là
maintenant il faut que ça se mette en
place
il y a une équipe au ministère de la
Santé qui est en train d'y travailler ça
peut être vrai pour les bars ça peut
être vrai pour les restaurants ça peut
être vrai pour certains
établissements recevant du public comme
les magasins je pense que il faut voilà
dans ces dans ces endroits où on côtoie
des gens qu'on ne connaît pas souvent on
n'a pas de masque ça peut être utile
mais encore une fois je pense que le
principal c'est que
et cette volonté collective de relancer
le stop covid pour le pour répondre à
votre question je pense que
c'est ta responsabilité du gouvernement
il faut pas se défausser mais
je pense qu'il y a une parenthèse dans
les semaines qui viennent compte tenu de
la résurgence de l'épidémie compte tenu
de ce qu'on voit à l'étranger pour
relancer ce top covid et on doit le
faire de manière collective c'est pour
ça que on a besoin aussi de gens qui
nous aident à le pousser
monsieur Assouline prend la suite
oui vous vous avez répondu dans le micro
à quelque chose que j'ai dit en aparté
mais qui ne faisait que que relever ce
que vous nous expliquez est-ce que vous
avez expliqué
vous dites que ça ne marche nulle part
alors je suis en droit quand même de me
dire
pourquoi vous vous obstinez
c'est pas une question de culture
française de méfiance c'est depuis le
début de cette épidémie
quelque chose qui est de votre
responsabilité politique au gouvernement
si on vient expliquer que les masques ne
servent à rien et qu'aujourd'hui dans
cette salle nous sommes obligés de les
porter les Français doutent de ceux qui
l'auront parlé au moment fort de
l'épidémie
quand on dit que il faut tracer
et il faut tester il faut tracer et il
faut isoler et qu'au moment où il se
ruent sur les tests rien n'est prêt
n'est que sont interminables les
résultats viennent huit jours après que
personne souvent dans la région
parisienne ne reçoit de coup de fil pour
tracer et qui a pas de solution
d'isolement alors la confiance elle ne
peut pas être au rendez-vous et c'est
encore de votre responsabilité et si
vous lancez une application
et qu'elle ne marche pas c'est dans
toute entreprise qui lance entre
guillemets un produit quant à le lance
et ça marche pas ils se disent pas c'est
la faute du client
ils disent c'est de ma faute donc à un
moment donné il va falloir que vous
regardiez votre responsabilité pour que
la confiance revienne et évidemment que
sur une question aussi essentielle
que les données personnelles il faut
beaucoup de confiance ça dépasse
l'épidémie et stop covid
vous êtes au coeur dans votre
responsabilité d'un sujet ou beaucoup de
citoyens dans le monde pas seulement en
France sont inquiets parce que les
données personnelles sont pillées à une
échelle de masse on ne sait pas qui à
quoi comme donner à chaque fois là on a
un portable tous en face de nous mais on
sait très bien que sur une des bases de
données on sait exactement
où nous sommes en ce moment et parfois
même ce qu'on peut dire
et ça va continuer avec intelligence
artificielle etc donc l'enjeu éthique et
l'enjeu politique nécessite une
éducation une transparence et une forte
autorité en termes de confiance des
gouvernants
il y a pas situation plus favorable
entre guillemets qu'une épidémie ou les
Français sont prêts à sacrifier pas mal
de choses
pour éviter de tomber malade ou de faire
tomber malade quelqu'un pour dire mais
si cet outil peut me servir à quelque
chose même si j'en doute un peu je vais
le télécharger parce que il s'agit de la
vie de la mort et malgré cette crainte
qui a été perceptible des Français que
nous avons encore il ne télécharge pas
alors la première question c'est quand
allez-vous assumer que peut-être vous
vous êtes mal pris et que peut-être il y
a une responsabilité de ce qui gouverne
dans cette question vous voyez
je vous laisse à votre imagerie sur la
foire elle épouse ma question elle est
celle que se pose beaucoup de Français
et moi je suis quelqu'un qui prône de
s'engager dans les révolutions
technologiques et la révolution
numérique en particulier je ne regarde
pas dans le rétroviseur
mais il faut regarder lucidement tous
les enjeux éthiques qui a devant nous et
à ce moment là en conséquence
rassurer donner confiance et il faut
qu'au moins ce qui est fait manuellement
de façon classique
coup de téléphone pour tracer
hôtel pour isoler soit là parce qu'on se
dit à quoi ça sert si je j'ai une alerte
alors qu'il y a pas de suite derrière
si je fais un test à quoi ça sert si je
l'ai huit jours après mon résultat donc
tout ça s'améliore etc heureusement mais
je voulais quand même vous interpeller
sur le fait que
il faudra un peu plus de stabilité dans
les messages du gouvernement y compris
sur STOP covid pour que on puisse
recréer cette confiance
alors Monsieur le setter je vais être
extrêmement rapide pour vous répondre
si les Français n'ont pas téléchargé
cette application et si les Français
vraisemblablement selon les études que
nous faisons ne comprennent pas
exactement quel est leur bénéfice ce
gouvernement et moi-même en particulier
en prenant toute la responsabilité
si je vous ai donné l'impression de me
pardon si je vous ai donné l'impression
de me défausser
sur ce fait là alors c'est une erreur de
ma part
je suis extrêmement clair sur ce sujet
c'est
il va on va de la c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que j'évoquais dans mon la
question sur les causes l'action de la
pédagogie et la question de
l'explication et de la clarté on peut
considérer un certain nombre de
d'éléments mais oui je prends ma part de
responsabilité pleine et entière dans le
fait que cette application est
insuffisamment rencontrée son public
merci bien monsieur lévrier prendra la
suite et la fin merci monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur le Ministre une
petite question rapide sur la confiance
première chose je me suis toujours posé
la question depuis le début sur cette
application et sur beaucoup et sur le
masque aussi sur la logique victime
coupable et j'ai le sentiment peut-être
à tort mais c'est peut-être une piste à
creuser que les gens se sentent
coupables alors qu'ils devraient se
sentir victime et que cette application
il faut le regarder en une logique de
victime et non pas de coupable et que
c'est peut-être un des problèmes qui
fait qu'elle est pas téléchargée je veux
pas savoir parce que je vais être
coupable si je suis contacté question
autre question pour la confiance vous
avez expliqué et si je dis que vous
m'avez convaincu tous mes collègues vont
sourire
que notre système 5 vous avez proposé
qui est centralisé était finalement le
moins mauvais de tous ceux qui étaient
en place actuellement le plus rapide en
tout cas déjà en termes de diffusion de
de mise en place est-ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un travail fait avec nos
partenaires européens pour que eux aussi
changent d'avis et nous rejoignent sur
ce procédé ce qui donnerait peut-être
beaucoup plus de confiance aux citoyens
qui se dirait ah tiens finalement
l'Europe se met se remet au travail sur
un sujet commun qui est qui serait une
application commune merci de votre
réponse
alors sur la question victime coupable
on m'a veillé à une chose depuis le
début ce qui d'ailleurs en partie
handicap le fonctionnement de plus
efficace de l'application c'est de
préserver à fond la vie privée
et de laisser le total libre arbitre aux
Français de télécharger ou pas
l'application je rappelle que
ne sera jamais question de forcer ou
dans en obligatoire
et par ailleurs d'être les seuls à
pouvoir avoir y avoir accès je rappelle
qu'on a même précisé que toute personne
tout employeur qui forcerait le
téléchargement ou force ou irrévoir sur
l'application de son
de son employé pourrait être passible de
poursuites pénale employeur d'ailleurs
ou cafetier ou restaurateur on ne peut
que recommander et il y a un pari qui
est fait largement qui est celui de la
voilà du libre arbitre et de la
responsabilité des Françaises et des
Français et donc aujourd'hui si demain
vous recevez
si demain deux choses soit vous c'est
vous qui êtes malade et vous scannez
votre QR code vous l'envoyer chez vos
éventuels contacts enfin vous envoyez la
notification si vous éventuelles le
contact personne ne sait que c'est où
deuxièmement à l'inverse c'est vous qui
recevez la notification vous n'avez
aucun moyen de savoir d'où vient la
notification
après c'est à vous de prendre la
décision de d'aller vous faire tester
pour savoir si de quel contact vous
passez à cas positif mais ça ça relève
de la relation de qualité individuelle
de chacun mais vous n'êtes personne ne
vous dira jamais personne ne le saura
jamais donc ça relève de votre
responsabilité individuelle sur la
discussion avec des partenaires
européens pour le dire très sincèrement
je pense qu'il est trop tard
je pense que ce débat est derrière nous
je pense qu'il y a 15 millions de
Britanniques qui l'ont téléchargé parce
qu'il y a 18 millions d'Allemands qui
l'ont téléchargé je crois que ce sont
les chiffres
bon on finira avec deux applications
différentes puisqu'elles sont par
essence non interopérables c'est dommage
c'est dommage à divertitres mais voilà
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
je reste persuadé que nous avons fait
les bons choix
merci bien monsieur ministre y a-t-il
d'autres questions non
voilà donc complètement informé
et Merci à VOUS bon après-midi et bon
courage pour la suite merci monsieur le
président